let's say I've got an m-by-n matrix a
that's my matrix right there and I could
just write it as a series of n column
vectors so it could be a 1 a 2 all the
way to a n now let's say that I have
some other vector B let's say V B is a
member of the column space of a and
remember the column space is just a set
of all of the vectors that can be
represented as a linear combination of
the columns of a so that means that B
that means that B can be represented as
a linear combination of the columns of a
so I'll just write the constant factors
as x1 times a1 plus x2 times that is a1
plus x2 times a2 all the way to plus
plus X n times a n where X 1 X 2 xn
they're all just arbitrary real numbers
or that another way to state this is
that that means that a which I could
write as a1 a2 all the way to a n times
some vector some vector x1 x2 all the
way to xn is equal to B these two
statements are equivalent we know that B
is a member of the column space that
means that B can be represented as a
linear combination of the columns of a
and then this statement right here can
be rewritten this way so you can write
that the equation a x equals B has at
least at least one solution X that is a
member of RN and the mem the entries of
X would represent the weights on the
column vectors of a to get your linear
combination B this is all a bit of
review now let's draw our n are any
solution to this equation right here is
going
be a member of RN remember this is an
m-by-n matrix with n columns this has to
be it a member of RN right there so
let's draw our n so our n maybe looks
like that so that is our n and let's
look at some of the subspaces that we
have in RN we have the null space that's
going to be an RN the null space is all
of the solutions to the equation ax is
equal to 0 that's going to be an RN it's
all of the X's that satisfy that
equation so let me draw that right here
so let's say I have the null space right
there so that is the null space of a and
then what else do we have in RN well we
have the orthogonal complement of the
null space of a we draw that so we have
the orthogonal complement I'm doing a
different color we have the orthogonal
complement of the null space of a so the
orthogonal complement of the null space
of a which we can also call we learned
this in the last video this is also
going to be equal to the row space of a
the row space of a which is also just
the column space sorry the row space of
a the row space of a is the column space
of a transpose so we have two spaces
here this is that is the row space row
space of a so have two subsets of RN I
have the null space and then I have the
null spaces complement orthogonal
complement which is the row space of a
now we've seen in several videos now and
I proved it I think two videos ago that
any any vector in RN can be represented
as a sum of a member of of our null
space let's call that vector n and let's
say some vector in our row space in our
row space let's call that vector R any
vector in RN can be represented as a sum
of some vector in our null space and
some vector in our row space so any
solution to this equation is a member of
RN so it needs it it must be able to be
represented by some member of our null
space and some member of our row space
so let's write that down so let's say so
X is a solution so let's say that X is a
solution is a solution to ax equals B
which also means that X is a member of
RN X is a member of RN or X is a member
so because it's a member of RN we can
represent it as a lit as a combination
of one vector here and one vector there
so let's say that let's say that X X is
equal to some vector R let's call it R
naught plus N naught where where R
naught is a member of our row space is a
member of our row space and and not and
not is a member of the row spaces
orthogonal complement they're they're
orthogonal complement of each other so n
naught is a member of our is a member of
our null space fair enough now one thing
we might wonder is clearly this vector
isn't the solution to ax equals B this
vector is a solution to ax is equal to 0
but we might be curious as to whether
this solution right here this member of
our row space is a member of is a member
is a solution is a solution to ax is
equal to B this is kind of what we're
focused on in this so let's solve for R
naught right here
so if we solve for R naught if you
subtract n naught from both sides we get
R naught is equal to X minus n naught
all I did is subtract n naught from both
sides and I switch things around I
solved for R naught now if we multiply a
times R naught a times R naught is equal
to a times this whole thing we switch
colors that's equal to a times X naught
minus n naught which is equal to ax
minus a
let me write that - so - let me write -
a and not and what is this equal to
well a times X we already said that X is
a solution to ax equals B so this right
here is going to be equal to B and n not
is a member of our null space which
means it satisfies this solution right
here that a times any member of our null
space is going to be equal to the 0
vector so that's going to be equal to
the 0 vector
so you have the vector B - the 0 vector
and you're just going to have the vector
B so we just found out that a times this
member of our row space let's call that
R naught that's that guy right there
maybe a times R naught is equal to B so
this is a solution so R naught R naught
is a solution is a solution to a X is
equal to B so so far it's kind of an
interesting and interesting result that
we have already if you give me any
vector here B that is a member of our
column space right then there is going
to be some member of our row space
there's going to be some member of our
row space right here that is a solution
to ax is equal to B now the next
question you might wonder is is this the
only guy in our row space that is the
solution to ax is equal to B and to
prove that let's assume that there's
another guy here let's say that let's
say that r1 is a member of our row space
and a solution and a solution to ax is
equal to B now the row space is a valid
subspace so if I take the sum or the
difference of any two vectors in the row
space
I'll get another member of the row space
that's one of the requirements for
linear for for being a for being a valid
subspace so let's see this so if I take
two members of our subspace so if I take
R 1 - R naught and I take their
friends which is just the sum of its a
sum while you multiply 1 times a
negative and that has to be a member of
the subspace and then you're summing
them so this has to be a member of our
subspace so this must also be a member
of our of our row space that's because
our row space is a valid subspace you
get two of its members you take its
difference that also has to be a member
fair enough
now let's see what happens when you
multiply this guy by a so if I take a
times R 1 minus R naught what do I get I
get a times R 1 minus a times R naught
we already figured out or what for our
one we assumed that it is a solution to
ax is equal to B and R naught we already
found out it is a solution to ax equal
to B so either of these when you
multiply them by a it equals B so this
equals B and that equals B so you get B
minus B which is the zero vector now
this is interesting this tells us that
our minus R naught is a solution to the
equation a X is equal to 0 right when I
put R 1 minus R naught in the place of X
right there and I multiplied it times da
I got 0 I got zero which implies that R
1 minus R naught that this vector is a
member of our null space so I have a
vector here that's a member of my row
space it's a member of my row space then
we got that from the fact that both of
these are the member are members of our
row space and the row space is closed
under addition and subtraction and the
vector R 1 minus R naught is a member of
my null space and we've seen this
several times already if I have a vector
that is in a that is in a subspace and
it's also in the orthogonal complement
of the subspace right the null space is
also the orthogonal complement of the
row space then the only possible vector
that that can be is the zero vector
that's the only vector that's inside of
a subspace and it's orthogonal
complement or a subspace and it's
orthogonal complement these two guys are
the orthogonal complement of each other
we drew it up here
so we get that R 1 R 1 minus R 0 must be
equal to the zero vector that's the only
vector that's in a subspace and it's
orthogonal complement which implies
which implies that R 1 must be equal to
R naught if we when we take the
difference we get the zero vector so we
have a couple of neat results here if if
I have some what do we know so far we
know that if we have some vector B that
is a member of our column space of a
then there exists then there exist there
exists a unique member right we just
prove the uniqueness there exist a
unique member of the row space of a let
me write it of the let me do it in a
different color of the row space of a so
this is the row space row space of a
such that let me a unique remember
member of the row space of a let me call
that let me call that are not let me do
it in a different color I want to make
this really stand out in your brain are
not so we know that R naught is a member
of the row space of a such that such
that are not let me write it this way R
naught is a solution to a X is equal to
B which is kind of it's a little bit of
a complex statement here but it's
interesting you give me any bead that's
a member of the column space of a then
there will exist a unique member of the
row space of a that's my unique member
of the row space of a that is a solution
to ax is equal to B now we can go
further with this we can go further we
wrote up here that X
at any solution any solution to this
equation ax is equal to B can be written
as a sum of are not plus n not where are
not as a member of our row space and n
not as a member of our null space and
that's because we have a subspace and
it's orthogonal complement so any member
of RN can be represented to the sum of
those of a member of a subspace and a
member of the subspaces orthogonal
complement so let me rewrite that down
here so we already said that any
solution any solution X to ax is equal
to B can be written can be written as as
a combination let me write it this way
as as a combination of are not plus and
not fair enough now what happens if I
were to let's say what if what happens
if I wanted to take the square of the
length of X on both sides of that so let
me write this down and you'll see why
I'm writing this because I have another
interesting result to show you so if I
were to take the square of any solution
of any solution to this equation right
here right any solution to that equation
right there well that's going to be the
same thing as X dot X which is the same
thing as this thing dot itself same
thing is are not plus and not dot R not
plus and not and what is this equal to
this is equal to R naught dot R naught R
naught dot R naught plus n naught dot R
naught plus n naught dot R naught plus n
naught dot R naught again plus n naught
dot R naught again Plus and naught dot n
not and not dot and not I just kind of
foiled it out and we and we can do that
because we know the dot product exhibit
the distributive property so this thing
right here is equal to the length of our
naught squared
now that we're going to have plus well
we what is what is n naught dot R naught
what is n naught dot R naught we don't
even have to simplify this much more and
not as a member of our null space R
naught is a member of our row space they
are in they are each of them is in a sub
space that is the orthogonal complement
of the other which means that everything
here dotted with anything in here is
equal to 0 so R naught that and naught
is going to be equal to 0 there in the
these guys are orthogonal to each other
so that's going to be equal to 0 that's
going to be equal to 0 and then you get
you get plus what's this n naught that n
naught is just the length of the vector
and naught squared these are all vectors
and so we get the length of the vector x
squared the length of the vector x
squared is equal to the length of our of
our member of our row space squared our
unique member of our row space squared
plus that member of our null space
squared now this is definitely going to
be a positive number that's definitely a
2 it sits at minimum 0 but it has to be
something larger than 0 so we can say
that this quantity right here is
definitely greater than or equal to just
our not just our naught squared or
another way to think about it is you
give me any solution
you give me any solution to the equation
to the equation ax is equal to B and the
square of its length is going to be
greater than or equal to the square of
our knots length or since both of those
the lengths lengths are always positive
you can take the kind of a positive
square root you know you won't have to
switch signs there that the length of
any solution to ax equals B is going to
be greater than or equal to the length
of our knot
so that makes our not kind of a special
solution so now let's write our entire
statement everything that we've learned
in this video so let for so if B is a
member of the column space of a then
there exists then there exists a unique
a unique
are not that is a member of the row
space of a that is a member of the row
space of a such that such that are not
is a solution to a X is equal to B and
not only is it a solution it's a special
solution are not is the solution the
solution with the least or no solution
has a smaller length than are not let me
write it that way maybe some other
solution could be equal lets could have
the same length so and no solution can
have no other solution no other solution
can have a smaller length maybe we could
write that if you give me any vector B
that's a member of the calm space of a
then there is exist a unique member of
the row space a unique member of the row
space that is essentially the smallest
solution you know we could write small
as having the least length to ax is
equal to B which is a pretty neat
outcome in the next video we'll explore
this a little bit more visually